über die korona app möchte ich jetzt
sprechen mit spd gesundheitsexperte karl
lauterbach guten morgen herr lauterbach
kommen wir zunächst mal zur app glauben
sie wir sollten uns die weiterhin
runterladen nacht nachdem fünf wochen
ist ja diese fehlermeldung gar nicht gab
guten morgen zunächst haben wir ja die
maßnahme funktioniert und also somit
darf man also zahlt den eindruck hier
stehen lassen dass die app also runter
geladen war und nicht gewarnt hat
sondern die maßzahl für die meisten
nutzer hat die app ihre arbeit getan
trotzdem ist das ein also fehler die
nicht also so lange unentdeckt hätte
bleiben können dürfen
ich bleibe aber dabei die app ist
dringend notwendig wenn wir haben uns
heute welle verhindern wollen müssen
mehr leute die app nutzen
die app wird rasant verbessert für die
aller maßen hat sie ihre arbeit getan
sie wird für alle die arbeit in zukunft
tun ich habe lieber dafür weiter
runterladen und bitte mal benutzen
ich habe selbst schon mehrere risiko
begegnungen gehabt und die app hat mich
entsprechend gewarnt und also von daher
funktioniert die app und ich nutze sie
auch selbst
dennoch wurden ja fünf wochen lang
nutzer bestimmter geräte nicht gewarnt
ist das jetzt eine blamage für die
bundesregierung
sie wurden nicht immer nicht gewarnt
also sind auch zu beantworten sind
manchmal nicht gewarnt worden ist
sozusagen zeitweise ausgefallen
ich glaube nicht dass die regierung sich
hier blamiert hat das ist ein software
fehler gewesen die den jungen hat ja nie
gesagt die app funktioniert einwandfrei
ohne also probleme sondern also die app
ist sehr schnell entwickelt worden ist
aus meiner sicht dass er weiter zu dem
zeitpunkt gewesen 80 vorgestellt wurde
kleine fehler waren ja bekannt von da
ich wurde nach vorne blicken und nicht
das was gewesen ist und die app muss
genutzt werden wir brauchen sie denn
sonst werden wir das risiko einer
zweiten welle also noch schwerer
abwenden können als es mit der app
können wir werden so noch genug probleme
haben somit nur der app sollte genutzt
werden haben wir zu sprechen
das auf den fall aus mallorca urlauber
kehren zurück sind mit dem virus
infiziert sein wir jetzt alle
urlaubsrückkehrer testen lassen
in der tat würde ich das für sinnvoll
finden und zwar deshalb wir müssen davon
ausgehen dass aus den urlaubsgebieten
und zwar nicht nur aus den
risikogebieten kohl nach positiv zum
testende zuge kommen wenn die nicht am
urlaub software getestet werden sondern
aus jetzt nach hause kommen werden die
maßen ist gefasst werden wenn sie jetzt
symptome haben bis dahin können sie im
flugzeug oder auch also nach der
rückkehr viele andere schon wieder in
deutschland gezielt haben wir haben ein
größeres risiko einer zweiten welle
um dies zu reduzieren wäre es eine gute
investition die reiserückkehrer
insbesondere diejenigen die mit dem
flugzeug zu bekommen und lukas schon
bereits zu testen auch andere sollten
zum test aufgefordert werden weil es ist
einfach so bei der urlaubsreise ist das
risiko sich zu infizieren höher
auch für diejenigen über die sich
vernünftig verhalten haben denn bei der
reise selbst kann dann anderen begegnen
die infiziert sind weil sie sich zum
teil nicht optimal verhalten haben soll
das ihrer meinung nach nur für mallorca
rückkehrer oder dann doch für rückkehrer
aus einem urlaub ländern gelten
nein das sollte aus meiner sicht für
alle urlaubsländer gelten
das halten dass sie auf mallorca gesehen
haben was hier anders zu sorgen gibt
senior an vielen anderen plätzen für
viele andere urlaubs plätze gilt das für
die touristen ist und auch für die
deutschen touristen bestimmte regeln
ausgesetzt worden sind zum beispiel das
dann in den abendlichen also stand passt
also keine masken getragen werden müssen
die abschnitt auch nicht eingehalten
werden müssen er war wie in deutschland
zurecht
also anderthalb meter abstand also von
tisch zu tisch verlangen und also auf
dem weg zur toilette zum beispiel durch
das restaurant also masken verlangen ist
dass sie den allermeisten restaurants
und in den allermeisten bars im ausland
ausgesetzt
die gäste sich ganz anders halten da
begegnet man fremden die ebenfalls
risikoträger
sind somit ist die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass man sich dort infiziert hat viel
höhe
ich würde es daher für alle reisen
würden für sinnvoll erachten sie
sprachen vorhin eine mögliche zweite
welle an worauf müssen wir uns im herbst
einstellen was glauben sie ich glaube
dass es eine zweite welle geben wie groß
sie sagen sondern wissen wir nicht aber
ich glaube an eine zu harte welle wir
haben auch jetzt noch relativ viele
fälle im hintergrund und also
dunkelziffer ist deutlich höher ich
rechne jetzt mit mehreren tausend fällen
pro tag die wir haben als zweite welle
würde bedeuten dass die auch jetzt
bereits positiven oder die jetzt immer
wieder positiv werden ergänzt werden
durch die reiserückkehrer und das durch
das innenraum aufhalten das risiko also
von super spieler und sehr viel größer
wird wir wissen ja das derzeit geplante
wie oft sozusagen nicht weiterläuft die
leute sich grünen nicht aufhalten
sondern wesentlich im wesentlichen
draußen wenn wir aber wieder mehr
innenraum aufenthalt haben wo keine
masken getragen werden wo man aus muss
ich ja so über längere zeit begegnet
dann also jetzt auch mehr infektionen
geben die schulen werden dazu auch ein
beitrag was das sehen gerade an allen
anwendern und das bereits der fall ist
es gibt ja viele länder die jetzt schon
die zweite welle haben es geht also
darum die zweite welle klein zu halten
und gut zu beherrschen und wir werden
sie nicht komplett verhindern können sie
halten es ja auch für möglich dass gar
kein impfstoff von gefunden wird was
bedeutet das für uns wird es also nie
wieder so werden wie früher
also ich sage ja nicht dass also wir
kann dem stoff bekommen werden sondern
wir dürfen uns nicht sicher sagen dass
wir nun bekommen die guten nachrichten
an der eben fronttüren auch mit zu der
lässigkeit die jetzt zum teil beobachtet
werden kann
die menschen denken demnächst kommt ja
schon der impfstoff und verlassen sich
darauf aber wir haben bisher nur im
wirkung gesehen das haus aus dem stoff
die genutzt worden sind also die erhöhen
die immunität was dagegen spricht dazu
schneller an dem stoff haben werden ist
wir wissen nicht wie gut diese qualität
die durch die impfstoffe kommt
tatsächlich auch eine ansteht
verhindert und wenn es so erreicht
werden kann dazu eine ansteckung
verhindern können
die meisten im dorf mit schaltern in der
phase wo jetzt die impf prüfungen
stattfinden die phase 3
also läuft jetzt an für vier impfstoffe
2 auf ihrer basis und zwar auf der basis
also adenovirus basis also das sind die
vier eben stopfen jetzt getestet werden
in wenigen wochen mehr wissen weil wir
können uns nicht darauf verlassen ich
sage daher nicht wie es wird kein
impfstoff geben sondern wir wissen nicht
wann er kommt und rechnen auch erst in
der mitte des nächsten jahres damit
portal
so lange müssen wir auf jeden fall
vorsichtig sein und können nicht zum
regelbetrieb zurückkehren
karl lauterbach spd gesundheitsexperte
vielen herzlichen dank für dieses
gespräch
ich danke ihnen